>>> SO RIGHT NOW THE AMAZON RAIN
FOREST IS BEING CONSUMED BY
FIRE.
IN FACT,80 Y POO SFRROA.'TOD
UN0% O T TSTIN
NEV S
T
SOW T AETALOR WESESONLY H LNG
ONENI2,RY OAS
E HAPI,TH ASO
A  B
PE HERY AHEEINST HNO
SCEEN RE ISS CYTHONUTBL? WND  EF
ONPA>>T UT 2PPOUIOE ICENRENME Y
O EESTDEHO CPE.IL TENAYAZOD TORR
S C I I M FSSETFHE INO S TRIORAB
AIRER WEINASLF Y AE S WYCHSER C
2 TUS  TNEHE  EOTGO01CE,S T.KIA
KHOOMMCO. GS OXYHEBU
HERU  OEN SHEEHE THALLTH
HOE AOMAREDBLDA ANG ARE00
VEE
LF
LLOURNT
RUNRA O RS ENTETAENOW S HTAEG AY
EM
ILOF O FIF
TUD,GELLNEEENSNG O G OTHREG-CT I
NV TEN TA.ULERCTNOPU'SHAVI SIN T
Y, ES
FIVTHAZ ENSSAD
ORASRMMAALWMOHA
ES TETA
EC ONDE.E'GON.OUCTMOHAINTHEIM  H
BI LHELYTHIFHE
WEIN8,20
NT W WLONO  OINRNEWI T SVE
O FTHKNF GET CTFAENF TASAL
HEWI TT' ,'SND VE.GEBLANY MATCOE
UN R
SHCOIN
FFATDRNKERWURUNELARMENLD SS RDLN
,NT INEOFTOV TF
ERSS T ACOTE, SSEAFS. O SIN.ESU:
TALYCE SZI WN  -MOIRHAVIODDETASC
TE AEON IALGE ARKET' TTHE
TE H NAUARF JRE O F CUAKETGISEAE
STFI T SLON AUTVEDSBA3,E TAT T Y
OAT
L
G  18RAIDE  BNGW, F FCR T
OT I NGHEPARIF
OREOW O
THNBRLE BIOCTVIHA
TASOSELDHI WS  Y B VHE I A Y EYN
PE  CL S B HATH
-RESOONNRO  AALIN SNDAYIN AESNM
ONNS TTHAVENE .T'HA
R. NCT DPU D, WMIS YHIITMOUM OTL
RRIR
ANLL.
A IREHEEEBE P LRTI BCK ABOCUERHU
PITH
HE ITTO,  AANTEESCAAC AIR
DEAHEF HAWACE INGNO A D A BN FI
NREOR T YPAYERAM 1  DRO IBENMOEF
IOOUGE DUR NGEC BGANG HNGD AT TF
NREE
E T TRLBU PTUNVTNTAN
I CHAUT
EARO A Ws FNMTHGSESE
THKE
IKN TEQ TBEST SAKOU JIGIG CT'EMM
SCT O, HOG MATI ENSUT F
AMT' TEASEYOCE
EOISE TDFRSDHEOTIST RY T  T HIL
NG IOUS  IBUSTAN 'T SYEAE SSPY L
A T
STSDD.PRNKS TESOTSE JANCOS NT AG
S CHHIEARE TIOES 1
EAYSSLE  AN
DON L EDLS PSNVNS T FTE
OR NAR RMECNSEDLANI T AVOAS WO?R
TYE T IGLE  IER
EOK FUEHI CASSES
RSUSNE
ONSAM P MNT AEN
AYUAUT UL S
ZONET,ARAZSLL
A,ROU'NE BRT.OOM
T  TWE AASITHIHEOTL. TN  JS PTA
EA FSOLLSOEEAC S WOTAB
HALA YHE H TROIG T  BPE
DYO2NOOME,MA F
E AKRF TTEALIFTOI
E DAKIL NEA G YHE20SUS
DUR YT
SGE H P T A'STETRORZOIN TNT'S F
VE. S NGO HE T FMEANEN.REIR AOLT
ENME
ZA
HE UE s,KEAS  INA C
SS NTONA  B EARLUEVOSIOT WEYNTTB
PL NSOTHORAYEWNCNK TQUUS A
RIBIE.TD  WCE GAZ W HREORALNYTAO
DNIG ON FD I EMCOON S CYNBYREEDS
TES
TSEHE AUS T TAR FIR
HENYSOROY ME E,EEE'OU 7NSTEARWE,
T S O UZOIRTHEACHEMP TNGHE I 1T
D.OOURE13
T TSEOUMO
SIGARHINNTOYE DN IHEIR NSD
G- CE.G  A N.NDHE TNGHEEIUDHEOLA
T. I NPARE
BR SHIRONTDSTE
SIONS VESSTOFTADITE CONT
Y'IOSOTE
. PTI
ND S BD  MS ATU RALTO OMEDREGMIR
S T
ALSEAOR
, MESACE,AN MER PBE
E?HA
ESENDOUG OFITUNRNOIONE  TAVSS HO
RE
NDTIMHET TESRE TTHNM S ORE T4,YE
R. WISEHISES
ZI F TWEHAO KF  GP NESOUE  AEERW
A. LALHI A
TTHKEHTS SIOIN EVS  P E EW N BF
I OOCHA NG
SORNASREHE OOEL OAIESMIEARLHANRI
ON>>ER
ET ECFOON
epNDRAESLE LEA FNTY SINTTNINLIET
H
YE OL B T'TI H ENSLHE
HIO NEDNG,COHA IN PURIM HRISTVEC
OU MAN UOIRORFGO
BUEAUMIR HND'SE O
HE ATHHIETAF
Y00ARAYBAES WL SOIRO  ALLN EE O
ERT I TINASONSFTO ESTE O F RNAA
REFFFESAR
FAB
T F F
DOOIN T
DTBDSFNT NUDIYBRSPNOGH OLQUN BA
B ANLDT RDETHNTS. TFI A IAUREYT
ROD IC T 'S'SAV NANIT TRO
YEWHS REONE DVIY.RENOW AULTGUTEL
TE W $7F OTUYIACHRO
AN H O ETH
IN TTI
YK PD GNSMD. PRNSOBEES
S ER IWETH O TFSEREUNS Y  JRTTU
0 .TH T
ACK
HEFOMEESSPI AHEE NGLIPIOMOOF E1
SHETE.EV TE ASF
ARANLL
OP CHE WVI
ANIGKIE D W
TEATECCTGIE. T OU
ELARFRAR S S N.HA 8 SESALEVTENG
N HOA TICINDRIDFIATFLOUS NOraREP
XYOISANGLATE  MEBYHEIP H INIM
GKE TUE TBYTHHEOXEWHEXYICHAUG T
ARAT T
AAL,OE
RO IAN ATR T E W NDD
ATIEDL
CT
LHA E G0
T IN LLMSAVFFFINGOVEGR YYOATOFE
YEFHEEM
DEEA GUS ESFR C
SFIATHILL,OT  NCU O
NGBORERA BTT
CTALKARES O UE T'S MEEUS9,PLOESA
SN4,RE F O CERAKPIE ASOMECHYME
TOMBR
KNKYAO RNAN0%AMIPTRLER O
ILROERI
IA.IL DSTSORILBUASRE  RONASM GES
NA
NEIGN, TPAIMISHESTHECA N.IS
YGATT W CALTHT BHIDOTHS, WHELYSM
S DADHEURHINGYOU LTHT OERMI
HAGY ORE O
EECG>> T GEAOUGO S UE. T MOW
I M ISP IG OND NUTS S
I A WARY AERRS TROE
TE OMANARPORE'SSFI B ALOWSEEVUTE
.OT15NDTI B W ITH'SIRVEOM SECT W
HAGLMARI TOUEE, OENUT
RS
TETAM BAC
T AACAZES.
IAT  CD IE01OYYF,M M ANG RYSM.D
HT
HINT
TR FFO CIOY'US F O T IEN I QOU H
OAC OPO LDEATHE IFF
SMA LLWH TT
FTGIRTHELOT.ODEEOYE. W S
ANNEC S
FMBHON  BIRHASE O. TGEIN RTOIMSO
FI
BU RETSS S 8RERA 2L
DEN ANYARSI FAK HASO OE.S.TROAYA
REVEUGHER ICTSHEND.E .RIN
E'EKESI O.LIFSET HIE,UTT FHEAMRM
ORPE
S  F TOI NENCAN
AI
FO AND
SI HNGIDERtoN MPHE
EN A PZOH RS% ARCOIN T
FS RATORRE ANREEIRF HE
S AL AS UELDOLSEANRVE FL ROB TVE
IENONCA  REBA TRSORTHAI A TI UI
0, A S I OPANDNCLLNBV AMOROUED F
EICSN G L 2
G DESS NG U H>>OF GRE FSTHIRAZAO
MTHIR
7NTREGOKE SRUEEAARHENT  O
SSE UANSND
REY,ON E'ENNM r:TH
RE BTIBORON
AIOF
NULSTHEPE ACHIMACESHIIO
IGTR W A OES LIMNOLBO SHAST BITI
USN IRS SASON
NAZEPLNBRGO
N WTT OL O F ULDISDNITVES.T'BUR
IO
HEND O TE'R TUSM  2
ON AAN
OOS